okay we've got a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p let's
take a listen to this voicemail and i
want to present this to you what do i
want to say about it this is Troy York
okay regular caller Troy York here is
Troy York he seems to think that he's
figured out the real problem with
polarized politics in the United States
and maybe no surprise to some of our
viewers the problem is that I'm a
foreigner causing problems in the u.s.
take a listen to this
yes mr. nettinger lack of knowledge on
politics and traditionally how politics
is run is inexcusable you have no
knowledge it's because of people like
you mostly foreigners huh is why we have
this bar bipartisan political division
that can't get nothing done what Trump
is attempting to do is return to the
days where Democrats Republicans
actually work together is there supposed
to get legislation and deals done right
listing your podcast again shows your me
your lanka's now it's in experience
getting to discussing these subjects and
you you really should be working at a
drive-thru at a Hardee's mr. Peck me
bipartisan politics gets nothing done
and deal-making
is essential for a democracy especially
one has more than one political party
but I guess coming from all right let's
cut it that's good
you know somehow I don't think the fact
that I was born in Argentina is the
source of lack of bipartisanship in the
United States it's it's very difficult
for me to believe that that's the case
sounds to me like Troy York has to plug
his phone in yeah he was on low battery
there you gotta get gotta plug your
phone I love Troy org I really do he
calls up with this stuff and it's so out
of nowhere all of a sudden the problem
is that I once visited Israel all of a
sudden the problem with American
politics is that I was born in Argentina
I I kind of envy being able to reduce
all of our problems into such simple
simple explanation maybe you should
start flattering him more and then he'll
go away I mean that's how you have to
treat the trolls right he seems to only
call back because we say we discredit
every single voicemail that he leaves
he'll call back with his other what is
his his a Hispanic character Oh No Luis
eyford it's a Cesar ah I don't remember
but Troy York has three or four
different characters that he calls in
with anyway on today's bonus show yet
another incident where a sign language
interpreter was communicating nothing
with his hand signals and a report
claims that 40 percent of American
adults sleep with a teddy bear and I
have a very difficult time believing
that that's the case
those stories and also a discussion
about some format changes to the David
Pakman show all upcoming on the bonus
show david pakman.com slash membership
to sign up and of course patreon.com
slash david pakman show also now gives
you access to the bonus show and the
commercial free TV show sign up
whichever ways best for you the bonus
show is next